All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
useful rules as usual. First,
please mute yourself during the
talk. If you have immediate
questions, you are welcome to
unmute and ask the otherwise,
please use the chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in the q&a session
at the end. Second, today's
seminar is open to external
audience, so no classified
discussion is allowed. Finally,
the talk will be recorded and
uploaded to our YouTube channel.
Now, let me introduce our
speaker. It is an honor to host
Peng Chen , who is currently a
tenure track Assistant Professor
in the School of Computational
Science and Engineering at
Georgia Tech. Previously, he was
a research scientist at the Odin
Institute for computational
engineering and sciences at
University of Austin, Texas at
Austin. Before joining UT
Austin, he spent a year as
besserer and postdoc at ETH
Zurich in 2014 to 15. He
obtained his PhD degree in
computational mathematics from
EPFL in 2014. His research is
driven by challenging problems
in scientific and engineering
fields that involve data driven
modeling, learning and
optimization of complex systems
under uncertainty, and focus on
scientific machine learning and
shutting the quantification,
Bayesian inference, experimental
design and stochastic
optimization. Today, he will
talk about derivative informed
neural operators, please enjoy
the wonderful talk. Now, without
further ado, let me hand it over
to your Pen by asking a random
question. Yeah. So if you could
attend a lecture by any
scientist in the past or persons
who he or she be?
Well, that's a very good
question. I would say. Well,
there are apparently a lot of
scientists that I like to learn
from and one of, you know, the
leading scientists that would be
Richard Feynman, physicist. And
I learned a bit more about it
there, you know, physical
background, and, you know, the
sort of like a first principle
models that, you know, we're
approximating today with the
DIRECTV environment and your
operators.
Yeah, that would be definitely a
good choice by many others, as
well. So thank you. So please go
ahead with your talk.
Thank you, Tony. Thank you for
your kind invitation and also
introduction. So today, I'm
going to share some recent work
on on to routine informed near
operators is a class of linear
operators, that are designed to
address and essentially
optimization problems construct
constraint either by and large
scale partial differential
equations, and also was that
many different applications as
Tony mentioned, and Bayesian
inference, optimal experimental
design and stochastic
optimizations. So this is joint
work with a team will go at
Georgia Tech, and was professor
on Mercatus Jintan, lower Tomas
only raspberry and on Bert
availa, from UT Austin. So, let
me start with a few examples.
The first one is the Bayesian
inference of Antarctica ice
sheet flow. So, here you can see
essentially the East our
satellite observation of the
surface ice flow velocity of
Antarctica ice, and over the
years, there is accelerated ice
sheet flow. And if all there
Atlanta ice mountain and getting
into the ocean, and there is a
significant sea level rise, so
care about this problem. Um, so,
the model itself can be
described by you know, their
their nonlinear viscous,
incompressible fluid flow,
essentially the stock's flow.
And uncertainty of the problem
depends on you know, the Bessel
sliding field essentially is a
boundary condition between the
boundary sort of like along the
boundary of the eyes and land,
so, we don't really know about
it the vessels sliding field
want to infer a dispute from the
observation data. And in
particular, want to find the
maximum of posterior point of
this parameter. And here,
there's a some reason to work on
finding this map point by
solving an optimization problem,
essentially a Newton best
optimization problem. I can see
here, this is essentially their
map point maximum a posterior
point of the parameter at the
bottom boundary. Apparently it
is a random field it is a random
variable at each point and is
infinite dimensional after
discretization could it be very
high dimensional The second
example is optimal experimental
design for tsunami warning. So,
here you can see essentially how
to deploy a surface boy and also
a smart meter. So, once there is
a earthquake in the sea floor,
and like the sea Flow Motion,
you can quickly detect the
acoustic wave from the tsunami
here and the surface boy and he
can pass it down to their
Tsunami Warning Centers. And
uncertainty of this problems
comes from you know, the slip
land earthquake fault. So,
essentially their earthquake
fault due to this pressure, high
pressure that generated the
tsunami, it is a dependent on
space and time. So, essentially
space and time dependent
stochastic processes is also
quite high dimensional after
discrimination. And so, the
model can be described by, you
know, this elastic acoustic
gravity wave equations. And also
once there's a tsunami
generated, it follows is a
shallow water equation. So, it's
essentially a tsunami is
propagated to the coastal city
where he commanded by shallow
water equation and the
optimization problem is
essentially we want to place the
sensors This is Sanaa meter and
a surface boy in order to detect
their Earth crack and also you
know, maximum tsunami warning
focusing and so, these sensors
are actually plastic to maximize
the information that it can gain
from the sensors. So, the third
problem is about stochastic
optimization with application
for direct yourself assembling
material, that is for instance,
potentially can be applied in
semiconductor error. So, here
what you can see is a dye block
a polymer. So, you have two
segments and have a different
like a foster track them to form
a different patterns. And so,
this patterns can be formed by
placing certain guiding posts on
certain the Socata guiding post
or substrate, so that the
materials can fall into the
pattern or morphology that you
want to Microsoft can be
described as either self
consistent field theory, or non
local uncanny valley equation
that I've been working on. So
here's one type of target in
mythology, and we're complex a
certain substrate for instance,
here complex a substrate and it
will attract the material to
form this target in mythology,
right and so, the optimization
problem would it be to properly
design the substrate or another
application, the target
mythology looks like this one,
and then we can replace our
guidepost. So, essentially, I
want to decide at their
locations that the guy post
cites that the equilibrium state
is driven as close as possible
to the target mythology or
wherever the problem is, you
know, there's a lot of
uncertainty in this system too,
there is for instance, random
initial phase of the materials
and the material properties and
also their temperatures of this
process. So, this uncertainty
are also very high dimensional.
And for instance, here at a
given optimal design, because of
this uncertainty, the
equilibrium can converge to in a
different sort of like stead
here you have a standard that
you want and that is close to
the target of mythology, but
however, there are some other
equilibriums that are sort of
like a defects of the material,
you want to minimize this kind
of a defects by stochastic
optimization problem. So, over
this three different examples,
we formulated a few like
abstract problems, the first one
is a forward uncertainty
propagation. So you have a
complex system described by a
mathematical model are you have
a steady variable you here and
now you have an uncertain
parameter represented by Sita,
Sita as an all the examples, it
couldn't be very high
dimensional, and have a certain
probability distribution and
then can propagated the
uncertainty off the parameter
served as a system to some
quantity of interest. For
instance, in a tsunami warning
system, you can predict their
water and web height or you know
the magnitude and so, there's
additional variable z z could it
be their optimization variable
experimental design variable.
So, the second problem is based
inference to given some data
which is typically noisy the
data actually you know, a
collection of some observation
of your static variable you hear
and you have additive noise,
Absalon follows certain a noise
distribution. So, the base
inference problem is actually to
characterize the posterior
distribution of the parameters
theta, which is you know,
proportional to the likelihood
function times the prior. And
given the data you can
effectively reduce uncertainty
of this parameter, and this
reduced the parameter. Reduced
uncertainty can also be
propagated to the or quantity of
interest, but one of the problem
could be like how do you in the
first place collect the data
right this is optimal
experimental design problem. So,
as you can see here we have
information again color
graphically you represent it by
calligraphic view. So, when it
maximize this information from
our experiment from our sensors,
and this is these stands for the
experimental design variable and
it is averaged with respect to
the data or the data. So,
essentially, we want to like
optimize our sensor locations in
order to collect the data to
reduce their uncertainty as much
as possible as you can see,
after the optimal experimental
design, you have a reduced the
uncertainty for the parameter
and again you can propagate it
to their point of interest at
this stage was a well calibrated
model, you can solve the
optimization problem. So, you
have some quantity of interest,
could it be likely that control
or design objective and this is
still is a random variable, you
want to compute a some
statistical measure or risk
measure, and you want to
minimize this risk measure. And
there is additional, let's say
penalization term or
regularization term. And this is
the here stands for optimal
control or design variable.
Alright, so, they're about like,
there's four different problems
with consider. And there are
some common challenges for this
problems. The first is the model
are typically quite complex,
disrupted by partial
differential equations have been
reviewing for this different
examples. And they're expensive
to solve and uncertain
parameters that they're high
dimensional, that could have
like a very complex
distributions as non Gaussian,
multimodal and locally focused
locally concentrated for
instance, and then additionally
the optimization problem
including the experimental
variable, their control variable
design variable, those could
also be high dimensional and
also non convex. To address this
challenge, we exploit the
following opportunities the
first is we can construct a
certain surrogate models with
the required accuracy and also
this surrogate models can be
evaluated very fast and
secondarily. So for the high
dimensional parameters. And
typically the front of the
parameter to the solution or to
the observables in your
inference parameter or to the
objective in your control
problem, those maps are
typically intrinsically low
dimensional, how to exploit the
the low dimensionality will be
one of the opportunities and
therefore the optimization
problems. Typically, for high
dimension or high dimensional
optimization problems, we can
use a derivative best method or
adaptive optimization method,
this method are typically
dimension independent.
Alright, so, let me proceed to
this forward problem as
essentially the forward
uncertainty propagation. And
there are many different kinds
of, you know, their uncertainty
quantification problem,
including the model reduction,
the polynomial house and
recently their new operators. So
when approximate the solution
operator essentially from the
theta to the solution, you are
some quantity of interest and
map, this quantity of interest,
it could be a scalar a vector of
function, and when approximated
by a neural networks, F, indexed
by that neural net web
parameters w. And there have
been several different New York
predators developed over the
last few years, including their
fear and your predator, which,
you know, sort of like
transformed their input by fear
transformation and building the
neural networks in the frequency
domain. And also there is a deep
own net D proprietary network,
where the output is represented
by sort of like a linear basis,
this base is constructed by so
called their trunk net chunk,
neural network. And the
parameters are mapped through
the branch net to the
coefficient of this linear
basis. And then there's a
sequence of development and
reduce basis architectures of
the neural operators including
their so called Deep Learning or
reduced auto models, and the PCA
networks, which essentially
apply the principal component
analysis for the projection of
the input and output map, and
also originally developed this
derivative in the form of a
projected neural network. And
also there are a couple of
comparison papers on different
new operators, including the
following two. One is, you know,
the comparison for the full year
new operator and depo net. And
another is a comparison of
including this two different new
operator and additionally, there
is a PCA net and there's some
other reduced basis
architectures. So one of the
conclusion from this comparisons
is, you know, for larger scale
and high dimensional problems,
especially those problems,
intrinsic low dimensionality,
this PCA net, and also there's a
pod deponent essentially, you
perform some projection of your
input output to load dimensions.
Those new operator tends to be
performing the past from the
perspective of cost and accuracy
trade off. I'm going to explain
a bit more about this point.
Alright. So, the first
development that we had there
was under this Socata derivative
being formed with a projected
neural network. So, essentially,
instead of the PCA a net where
you projected their input
parameters theta into PCA basis
or like a Kakuna live expansion
bases, we actually project it
down to their active subspace,
which is computed by forming
this Jacoby none of this Q
transpose this multiply this
Jacobian tacked averages back to
their distribution of parameters
theta, and then you compute the
Eigen value decomposition to
tackle eigenvectors at the
subspace which is active
subspace for there, you know,
the output at Q I know projected
their parameters into this
active subspace. And for the
output, it would be their pod
subspace, essentially, you
collect snapshots of the output
and perform the pod or SPD on it
and you projected there, I'll
put to this basis. And then
after the projection we have a
neural network sort of like
leaving very low dimensional low
dimensional input and low
dimensional output can construct
this neural network was much
smaller number of training data.
And this also corresponds to the
so called encoder and decoder,
but this encoder and decoder
actually constructed the more
explicitly using the
projections, and we have error
bound for the input in
projection trollee by the
training Eigen values and
essentially the projection
error, where if you have a you
know, the output the projection
from the input and output,
measure the our two cents there
can be upper bounded by their
trading off the Eigen values
from the input and output. If
this Eigen value is declared
pretty fast, then this error
could be quite small. Here's a
one example on haremos equation.
So essentially, here, we have a
parameters theta on the
velocity, and Adesina is a
Gaussian random field. And we
have a source term here. And we
have observations of a of this
state variable along here the
surface. And so we have the
input of projection, the input
parameters mentioned as 16,000.
And by projection, we can get it
down to let's say, a dimension
of eight or 16 or 32, depending
on the decay of the Eigen
values. And here we have two
different neural network. One is
our deep net. And also another
is without any projection for
this, two different neural
networks, we have a deep refer
them for the neural network has
2000, and also about 24 million.
So we have two different
projections. As I said, one is
the inner the PCA or the cow,
you're covering a lot of
expansion bases. So this does
not reflect any their any of
their you know, the solution
behavior before the active
subspace, you can clearly see
some wealth patterns, right. And
so here's the accuracy of a
neural net neural network
approximation was an increasing
number of training data. And we
have different projections
including Active subspace
projection, the carry
projection, and also was simply
draw some random projection
basis. And then we have the full
space neural network. So the
blue line indicates the accuracy
by the active subspace
projection. So essentially, you
can see was a small number of
training data, you already
arrived at quite high high
accuracy, and is better than the
other two projections, and is
better than the full space and
construction for the full space,
because you have a lot of deep
refer them, you need a lot of
training data to arrive similar
accuracy. Okay, so here's a sort
of like a scalability test,
because we have the projection
to the same dimensions, it is
independent of the input
dimension. From the parameters
theta, we have either 4000 or
16,000. And before the deep net
by projecting to the same
dimensions will have the same
dimensions for their neural
network, but the full space
would have different degrees of
freedom. And you have a similar
behavior for the different
projection your networks Okay,
so the second problem is about a
Bayesian inference.
So, here's the abstract
formulation of the Bayesian
inference, why again is our data
observation data living
dimension as as could also be
quite high and sea days
uncertain parameter, we have the
from parameter to observable map
f f is observation of your
static variable right. So,
essentially, this alpha depends
on your set of variables. And we
have added noise, which is a
Gaussian distributed as a cover
as gamma noise. And a Bayes rule
says that the posterior
distribution of this is theta,
given your data y is actually
given by likelihood times the
prior The likelihood is that you
know, the data are conditioned
on the setup. And then this is
normalized by this so called
model evidence, or normalization
constant and is actually the
integral of the likelihood
function respect to the prior
distribution. Since the
parameters theta could be very
high dimensional, this model
evidence term is typically
intractable for computation. And
there'll be other many different
kinds of methods developed for
solving Bayesian inference
problem, including the Laplace
approximation, which is
essentially, you build their
Gaussian approximation of a
posterior at the map point. And
there is a MCMC sampling
techniques and also many of the
variants floating, using, you
know, they're derivative
information using dimension
reduction, and there is a sparse
quadrature. So to compute this
high dimensional integral, or
some other high dimensional
integral was back to the
posterior, you can apply the
quadrature best on sparse grid,
and we will have some reason to
work on that using Asian best
sort of, like, rescaling of the
dimensions and sparse
quadrature. And then there's a
whole class of different
variational inference using
different transport maps,
including polynomials, radial
basis functions on neural
networks. So, here we focus on
just to find that maximum a
posterior point, which is used
in the Laplace approximation. So
assuming we have a Gaussian
prior, where we have the means
theta zero, and also the covers
gamma prior. And so the map
point is actually given by the
solution of the optimization
problem, where the first term is
a data misfit, it's a mismatch
between the data and also your
from parameter to observable map
weighted by the noise covers.
So, see here, this is the data
y, this is essentially the
satellite observation of the
flow velocity. And so, the
second term is a you know, sort
of like a regularization term or
your prior knowledge, this is a
difference between the cedar and
mean weighted by the prior
covers. And by solving this
optimization problem, you get
the midpoint maximum or
posterior point. So, here you
can see and this is a map point
22 from this optimization
problem, and then at this
midpoint, you can evaluate your
forward map from the CETA to f
evaluated map point. And this is
actually this is an evaluation
it was just quite close to the
data. But to solve this
optimization problem, you need
to either use a gradient best or
Newton best methods, where you
know this Cobian of the forward
map is involved or the Hessian
is involved if you use a Newton
Ambassador method. And then to
Well, in order to construct the
surrogate for this from
parameter to observable map, our
new operator on neural networks
that should be accurate not only
for the map from the CETA to F,
but also reliable for the
Chekhovian from Sita to the
Jacoby of f. So here's our
derivative informed a neural
operator, we have the same
projected a neural network will
have input a projection to the C
to our as a projection of our
Sita by this input a projection
basis of SY. And our neural
network is evaluated by you know
this neural network mapping the
button and also your times the
spaces of the output basis. So
now, to train this neural
network, we actually include
another term, which is the
Jacoby because we want to an
accurate Jacobian in our
approximation, so the last
function essentially includes
these two terms. One is the
small neural network for the low
dimensional input output here,
and also their you know, the
projected output. And then a
second term is the Jacoby and
this is Jacoby of the neural
network respect to the input,
which is the low dimensional
input, right? And so you can
compute the Jacobian and also
projected from the left and
right to the low dimensions. Now
instead of like a million by
million dimensions, you have
let's say a 10 by 10 dimensions
depending on your number of
projection bases. So how does it
perform? Let's see for
particular inverse problem with
the deceit flow, which is quite
simple. We have observation
points here and is our true
state variable and follows
elliptic problem, which is like
normal diffusion problem with
where the CETA is Gaussian
disability to as a cover is
given as this elliptic operator,
the fraction of the alleged lip
the operator, which is
corresponding to the Martin
covers, where I have a delta and
the gamma those are positive
parameters that can control the
correlation and also variance of
their random field and also we
have a Laplace in term. So now
to compute at the map point, but
we can replace our forward map
the F by our neural network
approximation, right this is our
approximation of the dyno. And
so we can actually solve the
optimization problem in low
dimensions in their input
projected a coefficient
dimension coefficient space. For
instance, here instead of the
original high dimensions, it is
simply in the CETA R, which is a
projected dimension, let's say
instead of millions, it is a 10.
And it can solve this
optimization problem in a low
dimensional space. And you can
replace the original forward map
by their neural operator. So
here are the results. Let's look
at the writer first. So we have
this array of different
quantities that were
approximated, including their
forward and backward dissolve.
And on the right is a without
Jacobian training, there's
simply like you're just training
for the f itself without the
Jacoby and it can see there is a
decay of air it was increasing
number of training samples, this
is a relative error. And also
you can observe the same for the
reduced Jacobian. So here you
can see we have the reduced the
Jacoby and we want to
approximate this reduced digit
Cobian. And this is the decay of
the reduced Jacobian in red. And
then in a green there is the map
point. So this is a map that we
approximated by solving the
optimization problem using the
dyno or using their neural
network without their Jacoby
training. But on the left, we
actually included the Giacomin
training, we can observe not
only the map of the SOF F here
and also the reduce the Jacoby
they're more accurate than if we
do not include the Jacoby
information. But more
importantly for the map point,
it is much more accurate than
this map point about a one order
of magnitude improvement. So,
yeah, this is a you know, using
their dyno to find it the map
point and via the optimization
and here. So, we have a mesh
size of 64 by 64 and also tested
428 by 128 you can observe
similar behavior and the neural
network size is the same because
the projection dimension is the
same again and all right. So,
now, let me come to the third
example which is the optimal
experimental design problem. So
here is in particular, for the
optimal sensor placement, for
instance, here for the placement
of the tonometer on a
strategically and the problem
can be formulated as to place a
certain number of sensors out of
a deep candidate of sensor
locations, you can have a like
really large number of candidate
a sensor locations and want to
select only a small number are
number out of it. So the
observable map f is given by the
Socata design matrix times the
observation at all the candidate
sensor locations. So design
metric is solve is a matrix of r
by D. And as you can see, here,
we have a nine kind of that
sensor locations, if we selected
the first sensor, and the third
place, where we have the first
row at the third, third column
is one. And you know if the
second one second sensors pick
it up to the fifth point, then
the second row has a fifth
column one or the others is
zero. So essentially, this
design metric is is a binary is,
in fact a Boolean, and is text
value of zero and one, the sum
of all the rows is one and a sum
of all the columns. Sorry, its
sum of all the columns is one
sum of other rows is a number
between zero and one. In fact,
it is either zero or one. So we
need to solve our condition
problem was back to this design
matrix. And here's a one
particular formulation which is
the best under variance. So, the
variance best optimal
experimental design, where we
have the optimality from the
statistic community that a
optimality or D optimality. The
OPT a optimality is defined as
the Tres of the posterior
covers. And suppose you have a
Laplace approximation, which is
you know, the posterior
covariance evaluated at a map
point and you take the trace of
it the trust essentially
measures
how uncertain it is how much
uncertainty you have, you want
to reduce this uncertainty by
design this video. So,
essentially, you want to
minimize respect this W. But
this tres actually depends on
you know, the realization of
your data y and also your design
and W so essentially boasts a
map point and also the
covariance will depend on this y
and w. So Tech Tech, the average
of respect to this wine and this
is theta and the D optimality is
the determinant of this cover
and since that of the Tres, now
the posterior covers under the
Gaussian assumption, it is given
by this term, so you have the
hessian of the misfit term, and
you have a you know, the hessian
of their prior regularization
term, which is simply their
covariance of the prior inverse,
and this will be the Haitian
term. So the Hessian term
involves a second order
derivative, you've actually
approximated by gauss Newton
Hatian. Here, you only care
about it the first order
sensitivity information, you
have that your Kobe value added
the map point and here is that
you can transpose this is Jacoby
and the noise covers. So
essentially, you need to compute
this map point, and also the
stick Cobian. Repeatedly again,
again, for a given data y and
also the design W. Apparently,
this is quite challenging for
large scale, a PDE, constrained,
optimal experimental design
problem. And so here, more
recently, we developed this new
Socata to grip teaming formed
Jacoby a new operator, where the
reason is because our dyno is
derivative informed the new
operator can compute the map
point and pretty well, as we
showed before. But however, for
the future Cobian, the
approximation error is actually
quite large, are reduced the
Jacobian that we measured is
relatively small, but for the
computation of the food
Jacobian, which is needed here,
as approximation is actually
quite bad. So we developed this
Jacoby new operator, where we
perform a kopien projection,
first of all projected with
Chekhovian projection onto the
subspace formed by the active
subspace. And then we have
reduced that Jacobian. We
vectorize it again, for many
different snapshots at different
locations, and we perform
another SPD on it. So
essentially another projection,
and we can get a relatively
small dimensional quantity. Now
we'll compute a neural network
to approximate that Jacobian.
And then we can reconstruct it
this Jacoby and for this one, we
call this Jacoby newer or
brighter. And in fact, you would
wonder, you know, here you have
a parameter that can project
into different subsets right,
either a PCA subspace, and also
active subspace. And in fact,
for the computation of the map
point, and also their you know,
that Jacobian, the trust and
determinant, we need to use a
different projection basis for
the input. And here's evidence.
So on the left, we'll come
observe, you know, this is the
reconstruction of the map point,
you computed the map point, and
you project this map point into
different bases, either active
subspace or their PCs app space,
as you can observe here, if you
project it down to the PCs,
opsbase was increasing number of
bases, you get a smaller and
smaller error. But if we project
onto their active subspace,
they're still remains quite
large. And while the reason is
because the map point is
actually is a font, not only
with respect to the data, but
also there is a regulated
regularization term, there's a
PCA base is actually the Eigen
basis of the prior covariance.
And for the Jacoby to solve, you
need to project it down to the
active sub space in order to get
us more approximation error of
the Jacoby or reconstruction
error further Jacobian. And then
because of this, Jacoby depends
sensitively on the first order
information, right. Okay, so we
apply to this, Jacoby Nia or
predator for the evaluation of
the address and also determining
on the left it is a tres, we
have a defined element of trust
estimation. Essentially, we
don't use a surrogate here, we
take it as the truth. And we
have a neural network of trust
estimation, and it can see it is
very highly correlated. And we
have error, the mean of the
error is about less than 1%
standard deviations of 1.2%. And
for the approximation of the
determinant is about a 2.2.
Point is for 3%. Also as a
standard deviation 2.55%.
Essentially, they're very highly
correlated. So you can trust
your new operator to select your
sensors. Okay, now, let me come
to the last one of a stochastic
optimization problem. And so, as
I mentioned before, this
stochastic optimization problem
can be formulated as you want to
minimize a certain control or
design Z in a certain admissible
set. And you have sort of like a
risk measure or statistical
measure of your objective
function q. And then they have a
certain penalization term. Here
we consider a special risk
measure, which is the so called
conditional value at risk. So,
let me give you an example here.
Here's a density of your queue.
It is a one dimensional queue.
And so here's the value at risk
for given parameter beta. The
beta is sort of sort of like the
you know, better quintile, here
is the the probability. This
error is the probability and
this one is the quintile, which
we'll call this value at risk,
the conditional Value at Risk
essentially, the average or the
anywhere offer this quantity of
interest by the quantity of
interest larger than this
quintile. So essentially you
take the average of This curious
back to the probability density
here. So, the conditional Value
at Risk provides a more
conservative risk measure. And
in fact, it is often used in you
know, their financial
engineering risk management is
also called expected shortfall
the loss it varies between four
different better if a better
equals to zero then essentially
you can use the risk neutral
approximation risk unusual
minimization and if a better
because the one essentially care
about their extreme case, which
is worst case scenario
optimization and this is C var
can be reformulated as you know
the minimization problem, I was
back to a certain real number t
and then you have here as q
minus t, you take the positive
part of the thresholded for the
positive part. And since this is
that stretch holding is non
continuous is non
differentiable. So, we're sorry
it's not there's no Smos if we
want to apply any less a
gradient or hessian best
optimization method we want to
do some a smooth approximation
as exploit in this resin paper
Okay, so, for this oh yo yo
problem according to like
optimization under uncertainty
oh you you problem will develop
this so called multi input
reduce basis derivative, we
found it in your operator. So,
the reduced reduced basis is
quite clear, we use a reduced
basis for input output
projection, the bounded input is
essentially you know, we have
the input of the parameters
theta and we do the projection
of the parameter into low
dimensions, we also have an
optimization variable, so, we
have multi input right. So,
typically, here we can consider
either high dimensional
optimization variable or low
dimensions. And in particular
for this work we consider
parametric optimization
variables instead of function
valued optimization variables.
So, it becomes a relatively
moderated dimensions. And so,
now, we use the same pod
projection for the output will
build a neural network in
between and then we also train
our neural network by including
the Jacoby Ian was back to the
optimization variable instead of
respect to the parameter now,
because we need to solve the
optimization with respect to the
optimization variable and the
Alright, so, now, our data
generation and training are both
scalable in the sense in our
loss function as I briefly
mentioned before we project
everything down into the low
dimensional subspace including
their function itself and also
digit Cobian. And, so, now, the
quantity here in the last
function is actually quite as
more dimensional, but, one
particular point is you have to
compute this to Cobian right
that you Copening of us back to
Z, you have to generate the
data, we would have wonder,
could it be quite expensive and
but, in fact, it is not we can
solve it very efficiently by
exploiting that joint invest
measured. So, essentially here
that you're coping data
generation tax only this number
of additional linearized a PDE
solve and this number, you know,
the projected a dimension for
the output and also the
dimension for z. And, so, this
Jacoby and projected into their
output dimension is given by
this one by chain row of tech
that Jacobian and you would have
you know, this Jacobian of the
predicate PD operator respect
the state variable and this is
actually Cobian was back to z.
So, for this problem essentially
have to solve because this is
this becomes a linearized the
PDE operator at a given you
know, even if it is the PDF
itself it is nonlinear. So, you
can solve this sort of like
linearize the PDE operator
depending on their size of ru
and a dz you can solve either
here as a sort of like a
linearized forward problem or
linearized a joint problem
and then again, so, you have to
solve it for you know, perhaps
like a talent or 100 times
depending on this dimension
right. But in fact, here, this
is a SAM linearized operator,
you can just factorize it once
and reuse it as a director
solver or preconditioner. So,
here other two examples, let me
let me focus on the 2d navier
stokes equation to solve the
standard PDE you have about 13
seconds. But if a when are you
factorization is only three
second and after you factorize
it a subsequent how you solve
for this Jacoby generation TxA a
small fraction of the time. So
here's that cost accuracy
comparison for the audio
problem. And on the left, we
counted there a computational
cost in terms of how many PDE
solves that we need. So we have
either the new operator as As a
surrogate, or we can solve the
PDE directly, right as a
reference. So in offline, we can
generate the data, the solution
that you're hoping for the new
operator by solving a certain
number of PDs. And in offline,
we don't have to solve an MPD.
If we use a PDE, best that oh,
you measured, and in the online,
we don't have to solve any PD
for the new operator as a
surrogate. And above for the PD,
the CAS, we need to use some
sample average approximation to
compute is there a risk measure
or the C bar for instance, and
then we need to solve a lot of a
PDE is each of the optimization
step. And for the accuracy, it's
essentially an approximation of
the CVR. There is a apparently
bias from this surrogate right
but the variance can be very
small, because you can afford to
use a lot of samples to evaluate
this a C bar, but for the PD
UCAS there is no bias, but there
is a sampling error, you can
only afford it to solve so many
PDE is to evaluate the C bar. So
there is a stuff like this bias
and variance tradeoff. So here
for solving this or your your
problem, we can use either, you
know the surrogate, the new
operator or the PDE. And we can
measure the total cost divide
the number of us that a PDE
solves, and the standard PDE
solves, I use the for you know
the training data generation for
the new operator. And also, you
have to solve it if you use a
PDE best optimization. And then
we can solve the problem, we can
compute a some reference
solution or reference to choose
a solution, which is a solve all
the PDE best optimization
problem with a sample size in
the sample average
approximation, pretty high 4000.
And then now we can compare the
C var essentially at optimal
controls. And you can measure
the relative error against the
reference, this is what we're
going to do to measure the cost
and accuracy trade off. Here's
an example which is a flow
control or around a bluff body
we have a uncertain input
velocity field, it is a Gaussian
random field, we assume that is
only in one direction in their x
direction and as a customer and
a few it is Martin covers, and
we have control variable along
this two body which are
parametrized by B splines, this
phi of z is a control variable
and the z z is a parametric
control variable. Now I have to
define the objective function
when is the viscous dissipation
objective function which is, you
know, the sort of like a
symmetric version is the tensive
productive take the integral of
it. And another tracking type of
objective function, you want to
minimize the difference between
the u velocity and also target
velocity, we have a pin
elevation on the velocity on the
control velocity here with the
penalization parameter alpha. So
here's our discretization, we
use a non uniform mesh, and we
just tell her how to find the
element. We use alert and Lisa
square stabilization for to
stabilize the problem. And it
was weakly imposed boundary
condition for the duration that
boundary condition and it also
reduce the viscosity and
continuation to solve the
problem. So here's a full
dimension of the static
variables are 42,000 and they
reduce the dimension is about
200 and the parameter along the
boundaries, right it's more it's
about one unit one and it was
due to their you know projection
to this 100 and a control is
that 18 dimensional is
parametric. So, now, the full
neural network architecture is
actually quite a small the
combined input is 118 dimension,
the output is 200 dimension we
use hidden layer, the dimension
is that 402 hidden layers. And
here's the result, we have
minimize that viscous
dissipation without a control
here. And you can see there
viscous dissipation is
effectively minimize that by
solving this problem. Well,
let's take a look at it there,
you know, the cost, accuracy,
comparison or trade off. So here
we present three different
solvers. One is the PDE solver
in black, we don't use any
surrogate, but we use like a
certain number of sample average
approximation samples in order
to compute their C bar and this
is an increasing number of
samples to compute the C bar and
this is a total number of PD
soft along other optimization
steps and this is the relative
optimal cost error we can see
with increasing number of sample
average approximation samples.
You can have a smaller error
error further optimal cost. And
then here we have another two
different surrogate Why is it
without the Jacoby trainee and
when is the wizard your coping
training? So here this number is
indicated there number of
training samples, for instance,
here we just 256 training
samples we can achieve about at
this error that is a comparable
to hear the PD solve using this
number of PD solves. So
essentially there is about one
order of magnitude reduction of
total number of PD SOPs,
including other offline data
generation for the surrogate
models, and apparently this
Chekhovian 20. This dyno is much
better than their neuro operator
without your COVID. And here's a
viscous dissipation. And here's
a tracking type for the tracking
type, as even more evident is
essentially was about 256
training samples that are
achieved at the error that
cannot be achieved by the PDE
solve even up to this number of
total PDE solve about a two
orders of magnitude more PD
solvers, you can still can
achieve the same accuracy. So
essentially, our Mr. Dyno
achieves about like about 100 or
100 to attend to 100 more sample
efficiency compared to if just
to solve the PDS. Alright, so
here's an interesting
comparison. So here on the left,
which is compare the accuracy
for their solution in our to
error, right. So with the
wizard, your coding training,
about 256 samples we about we
arrived at about 200 or 2% of
error, which is larger than if
you're not used to coding
training. And but I've ever
further Oh, you your problem, if
you measure the optimal cost,
and is actually smaller than if
we do not use your coping
trainee. So essentially, this
Jacobian trainee, and does not
only help to improve accuracy
for the solution, but more
importantly, it increased their
accuracy for the Ojo solution.
Alright, so here's a few other
computational costs. So for the
2d in every stocks equation,
after you construct the one
valuation textbook this second,
and you can actually evaluate it
and batch wise as we did. So
about 2000, Assam posts, you can
evaluate them together, it only
takes about 0.3 seconds. And so
essentially there is a
acceleration about 100,000 times
compared to the PDS off. And so
here's the total cost breakdown
of the total cost. Let's look
again, for the Navier stocks, if
you just generated the data of
the solution without Jacobian
This is the time about a 13,000
seconds to generate the data. If
you include that Jakab in data
generation, it's only an
incremental cost is about 25%
more cost 16,000. So
essentially, all the costs are
actually spent on the data
generation, the pre processing
for you know the projection and
also on the neural network a
trainee actually very cheap
because we do everything in the
reduced the space.
Alright, so here's the test Task
Force 3d never stops the flow
control problem. Again, we have
this a similar setup, but it's
in 3d. Now, the steady
dimensions were merely the
reduced the dimension was two
years 200 And the parameter
along the boundary now is two
diecast is a 4000 and it reduced
dimensions 100 Again, the
control and dimension is about
50. So, each of the forward to
solve for this nonlinear 3d
navier stokes equation, it takes
about 30 minutes using 48 CPU
cores. And we generate about 448
samples for the training and
after the training we can ship
about 1.5% of the error for the
approximation of the solution.
And then each of the neural
network evaluation is about like
10 million times faster than the
PD solve. And more importantly,
we can solve the ODU problem
optimal control problem subject
to this uncertainty very
efficiently. And here we have an
uncontrolled cast for the
viscous dissipation and here
after their optimization, you
have reduced the viscous
dissipation and we solve this
problem after the construction
of a new operator we solve this
whole problem under one minute
and if you think about it, the
one PD is already tech 32nd 30
minutes and this is a very
efficient Okay, let me come to
my conclusion. So we developed
this derivative we formed a new
operators and all several of us
different variants. And as sort
of like the merit of the
accurate approximation for their
input to output a map right the
map offers a solution solve that
map of their from the parameter
observation optimization
variable to their objective
function to the observables. So
by using the dyno, this
approximation becomes more
accurate compared to without
using that Jacobian training and
more importantly, for the JUCO
When the salt becomes very
useful in the optimization
problem and becomes more
accurate, and we use the reduced
basis architectures, and then we
make the trainee in their
reduced space, so on this
training becomes scalable, as
independent of the nominal
dimension of the input and
output space. And only. And
also, we showed that, for this
dyno, it only requires a small
number for training data for our
test cases, compared to without
using that Jacobian. And, and
also, it is very powerful for
all these different optimization
problems, including, you know,
finding the map point and the
inference, optimal experimental
design, and optimal control
problems on uncertainty. So,
this work is sponsored by NSF,
DOE and DOD, you can find, you
know, pretty much the results in
this slides, and this for
different papers. Thank you very
much for your attention.
Thanks. Thank you for the
wonderful talk Peng? Yeah, I
find it very interesting. I
think our audience do as well.
So let's go to the q&a section.
Yeah, no, right now, we don't
have any questions yet. If the
audience have a question, please
like use the raised hand or feel
free to unmute yourself. By me,
I can kick off with a question.
So I, I myself find that they
refuse training very, I mean,
crucial and important question
to think about in practical
applications using all this
nonlinear structures. And I'm
curious about the details of the
Jacobean compression using the
basis that you show very, in the
very beginning. So in my
experience, this derivatives can
be much harder to compress than
the state variables. So that's
it. Yeah. To your problems.
Yeah, this is actually a quite a
good point. Because typically,
for the compression of, you
know, this f this map itself, it
is a much more, let's say, like,
it's much easier than the
compression of the Chekhovian.
And in our tests that has, this
decoding is also is quite hard
to compress. That's why we apply
this a two layer, sort of like a
compression first, and we apply
this input projection using this
active subspace evidenced by
here. And the active subspace is
actually quite crucial. If not,
then you'll see this
reconstruction error is actually
quite big if we just use a PCA.
And the second day, we do
another layer of compression by
vectorize, that Jacoby matrix as
a vector, and we perform another
SVD on it. So this is a
compression, like sort of like a
two layer compression from very
high dimensions as a matrix to
small dimensional coefficient
vector.
I see Yeah, this sounds a very
smart idea to like, circumvent
those issues. Maybe I can take
advantage of your smart idea.
And next time when I have to,
like do some compression to the
derivatives. Yeah, sure. Talk
more about it. Yeah.
So John has a question. So he
asked, When constructing a
surrogate is to always sample
the observation points
uniformly?
Yeah, that's another very good
question. So in our projection,
or construction, we actually we
sample that pretty much all
uniformly, we draw the samples
from, let's say, here, here hear
for the construction here, we
draw the samples according to
their distribution, let's say
for the parameters, theta is
Gaussian distributed, we draw
samples from the Gaussian
distribution. But this is not
necessarily the most efficient
sampling, for instance, in our
last class of stochastic
optimization, and if we want to
sample more meaningful or
helpful samples, for the C bar,
right, we would draw samples
from here instead of a lot of
samples here. And but we haven't
explored this idea yet.
Okay, so thanks for your answer.
So I don't see an error
question. So maybe I can ask one
more about the last very last
application that you talked
about the Yeah. The oh you like
yeah, the authorization? And
those are the I see, like, Yeah,
this is a fantastic sample,
like, I learned a lot, but, so
the model problem here is still
like, like a static I mean, time
independent case. So do you see
it like this? I mean, this
approach can be extended to
like, time dependent problems
and what will be the difficulty
is there.
Yeah, this is excellent
question. In fact, for this
different cases that I showed,
they're all All studies that
depends on their, you know, NEAR
operator approximation from
their input function to output
function. We're currently
working on time dependent
problems. Of course, there's a,
first of all, our framework
depends on the you know, reduced
basis architecture, in time
dependent problems, especially
for like, for instance, wave
propagation. This is an
unnecessarily low dimensional,
we can perform perhaps some
other like encoder decoder with
nonlinear dimension reduction.
And secondarily, we need to
adjust our new operator to also
take into account that at that
time input, for instance, there
are a few different a purchase
using like either a depot net,
where you have to type in the
trunk net, or like the newer PD
or newer od type of approach.
And there are also some other
different approaches that we'll
be exploring.
I see Yeah, thanks for the
answer. Like yeah, I find all
the applications very
interesting. And yeah, I think
many audience in the lab will be
interested in like knowing more
about your work. So thanks for
giving us the talk.